Speaker 1: Now, this is not only about
criticizing things, Donald Trump said.
We are now going to talk about things Hillary
Clinton said, which. Don't make a whole bunch
of sense. They make a little sense, but not that
much. Hillary Clinton over the last week or so
has really been talking a lot about
cryptocurrency. She's very concerned about
cryptocurrency, and she stumbles across a whole
bunch of things that make no sense. And a couple
that do. Now I'm going to remind everybody my
view on cryptocurrency. I'm not some big crypto.
MAVEN, and I'm also not against it in principle. I
believe that like every other financial instrument
stocks, bonds, real estate, precious metals,
foreign stock, you know, whatever cryptocurrency
is a tool. There are some who say it's not really
an asset class because it's gambling or whatever.
Okay, listen, I mean, at this point, it seems
pretty clear that at least for the foreseeable
future, crypto is here to stay. I have said that
my decision years ago was to get about three to
five percent exposure to cryptocurrency because
it's done so well. It keeps becoming a bigger
and bigger portion of my assets, and I then sell
it down and move into things that I consider to
be less volatile. It's a tool like any other. And
there are pros and cons like with everything else.
Let's listen to the first clip here. This
is from The Rachel Maddow Show and listen
very carefully to what Hillary Clinton says.
Speaker 3: I want to mention one other thing that
is on the horizon that people are only
beginning to pay attention to, and that's
the need to regulate the cryptocurrency markets.
Because imagine the combination of social media,
the algorithms that drive social media, the
amassing of even larger sums of money through
the control of certain cryptocurrency chains.
We're looking at not only states such as
China or Russia or others manipulating technology
of all kinds to their advantage. We're looking at
non-state actors either in concert with states
or on their own destabilizing countries,
destabilizing the dollar as the reserve currency.
There are so many big questions that the Biden
administration must address. I just don't think
we have much time. And therefore, I hope from
everything I'm hearing from them that that's
exactly what they're going to try to do now.
Speaker 1: There are little bits and pieces of
reasonable stuff. They're mixed in with a lot of
very strange claims. This was the second time
in this short period of time that Hillary
talked about cryptocurrencies. She also spoke
remotely at a Bloomberg conference, and she had
very similar comments to make. Take a listen.
Speaker 3: And then one more area that I hope
nation states start paying greater attention
to is the rise of cryptocurrency. Because what
looks like a very interesting and somewhat
exotic effort to literally mine new coins
in order to trade with them has the potential
for undermining currencies for undermining the
role of the dollar as the reserve currency.
Speaker 1: OK, I'm going to pause it there.
So first of all, she says, you're literally
mining coins. No, it's metaphorical mining.
It's computers doing stuff. Literally, mining
is actually mining. Mining means mining here.
What we're talking about is computers solving
cryptographic problems, doing it right. It's
not literally mining, which is just weird. But at
the end, there's something she mentioned twice,
which is really what this is all about the idea
that cryptocurrency might challenge the status of
the dollar as the reserve currency. Now there's a
lot of confusion in there. Hillary Clinton rightly
identifies that, for example, there are ways in
which countries could and can use cryptocurrency
to circumvent economic sanctions. That's a that's
a legitimate problem. It's a completely legitimate
problem, and there are proposed solutions to
it. But that's a that's a real problem. The
backwards part is the whole reason China doesn't
want crypto is because they manipulate the yuan
and they don't want something they can't control
to become common. OK. And so then you've got this
idea of the digital yuan and it's a complete and
total mess. But it's it's kind of the opposite,
like China's trying to keep crypto out in order to
not even have the yuan challenged. But she says,
well, they're going to use bitcoin or whatever
mainline crypto to try to destabilize the U.S.
dollar, which no one wouldn't be great for China
because they hold so much U.S. debt. And number
two, China actually seems to be going the other
direction which is just trying to ban crypto. And
it's really an example of one of the top skills
of being a politician, which is speaking really,
really confidently about something you don't fully
understand. She sounds like she knows what she's
talking about, and she stumbles across some things
that are real. But then there's a whole bunch of
other stuff in there that really doesn't make
sense. And it's actually sort of surprising that
the handlers of which she has many did not put
together kind of more coherent talking points.
But maybe those are the talking points that
they actually want. Now the other thing is,
there's always this kind of alluding to
cryptocurrency being used for crime. A new report
suggests about a third of one percent of crypto
transactions are related to criminal activities.
I don't think that's a very good argument against
crypto in my mind, but I think it's something we
hear frequently. But really, what this is about is
the U.S. dollar as the world's reserve currency.
China holds a ton of it. Japan holds a ton of it,
although you much more rarely hear Japan mentioned
because they're not considered adversarial
in the same way. But I think that listen, I.
How do I how can I say this? It's increasingly
seeming to me like crypto is here to stay?
And seeing people blindly say it's bad
and I want nothing to do with it, to me
seems more like digging one's head
in the sand rather than saying, Oh,
this is now something that is going increasingly
mainstream. Let me give myself a little bit of
exposure to it. And that's not financial advice
for anyone in particular. It's just the story
and of what I did in my thought process
in the three to five percent range for me.
And let's see what happens as part of a
diversified long term approach to financial
assets and tools. And at the end of the day,
I see cryptocurrency as a tool. Quite simply,
end of story. Let me know your thoughts. We'll
take a quick break and be back right after this